hi
i'm dan mcgrath i'm the product lead for
google's nosql databases
and i'm here in this session to give you
some insight into modernizing your hbase
workloads with cloud bigtable
but before we get into that i want to
give you a quick introduction into cloud
bigtable
and if you're already familiar with it
talk about some of the recent additions
to the service
and to kick that off i'm going to give
you a little bit of trivia that you
might not have heard
before because this year 2020
marks 15 years of cloud bigtable beaning
production here at google
we've spent a lot of time in that 15
years optimizing bigtable from the
experience of running everything from
small zonal workloads
to our largest and most demanding
workloads
with deployments spanning the globe here
is a diagram
from a design dock from one of those
very first deployments of cloud bigtable
showing a replicated system across three
regions
it was the following year in 2006 that
google released the big table white
paper
leading to the development of hface
after beating production for 10 years
cloud bigtable was released so companies
outside of google could benefit from the
same technology used here at google
and to make it easier for developers
hbase compatible client libraries
backed by bigtable were also released
now cloud bigtable is a fully managed
nosql document service
for use cases where low latency random
access data scalability and reliability
are very critical it seamlessly scales
from your first
gigabyte to data sets that are at
petabyte scales
it can handle millions of queries per
second
and as a fully managed service it allows
your team to be freed up from database
and infrastructure management tasks
allowing them to dedicate their time
to where the business can add value it's
completely compatible with the existing
apache hvac setup enabling seamless
migrations for existing hbase
workloads now bigtable
offers you a database that
provides speed scalability a fully
managed foundation and integration in
the google cloud
and apache ecosystem as its core base
on the speed front it does give you
consistent 99th percentile low latency
for random access reads and writes it's
the same technology that powers
a range of billion user google services
and it's proven in applications with
millions of database
accesses per second it easily scales to
match user needs
with no downtime it's a perfect fit
for real-time storage and analysis of
huge amounts of data
one of the really nice things about
cloud bigtable is it gives you
consistent performance
as your workload grows it can be easily
scaled by simply adding nodes or even
removing nodes
within the ui or command line interface
it offers seamless cluster scaling so
dynamically adding and removing these
nodes can be done
without restarts and the storage system
automatically scales as well
so you only pay for the storage that
you're actively using
through the separation of processing and
storage
cloud bigtable is able to automatically
configure throughput
by adjusting the association of nodes
and data
in the rebalancing example in the middle
if node a is experiencing heavy load
the routing layer can move some of the
traffic to a less heavily loaded node
improving overall performance resizing
in the third example comes into play
when a node is added again ensuring
balanced load across your nodes
ensuring best overall throughput of the
system
it also offers zero touch failover for
high availability and a range of other
use cases
bigtable enables you to write once to a
single replica and have it
automatically replicated everywhere with
eventual consistency
there are no manual steps to ensure
consistency repair data
or synchronize rights and deletes it
gives you the ability to have a
configurable topology and policies on
how to route data
both by the read and right side to
different replicas
common use case for the replication
system are high availability for your
live serving apps
or perhaps workload isolation where you
have both
user serving and batch workloads running
against the same database
it's also great for use case where you
want latency optimization
to write locally to a replica closer to
you but then be able to read that data
everywhere
perhaps in some centralized replica
where all your batch processing happens
so let's quickly talk about some of the
recent highlights
now on the fully managed side cloud
bigtable
integrates into cloud iam for user
access and authentication
at the end of 2019 announced table level
iam allowing you to have
more granular rules on who can access
data within clusters
we also announced multi-region
replication
to enable you to replicate data across
the globe as well as a host of new
regions
that rolled out to support cloud
bigtable
earlier this year in 2020 we also
announced
single node production instances so
historically with cloud bigtable
you are required to have three nodes to
be
able to be supported by the service
level agreement
now you can have a single node supported
by the same
sla that gives you 99.9
availability for single cost of routing
or 99.99
availability for multi-cluster routing
something that i'm really excited about
that we're just announcing now in july
2020 is the addition of managed backups
so manage backups give you a fully
automated
method to backup the tables within your
cluster
and then very quickly restore them
either into the same instance or perhaps
you want to
restore them into a development or qa
cluster
for ease of testing now let's have a
look at how you can think about
modernizing both your existing and new
hbase workloads with cloud bigtable
i like to think about it in terms of two
different paths
one is the backward looking path of why
you want to modernize
and this is where you're currently
struggling to maintain the availability
of your system perhaps you've had
durability issues
or perhaps performance when scaling the
system has been
become toilsome for your team and so an
example of this is where you're
struggling with stability at scale or
during peak load events
or you'll consider the operational load
on your sre and devops teams
too distracting from the overall core
work that you're trying to do
perhaps the overhead of managing the
replication system
repairs and the data garbage collection
system
has also become too toilsome for your
team cloud bigtable gives you a great
way to automate away
a lot of those troubles the other path
where people typically look at
modernization
is forward-looking so they want to move
up the stack and have
the development teams working on
something that's more focused on the
differentiators that the company offers
they want to spend less time and money
managing the complexities of a
distributed database
and have more time to focus on what was
not previously possible to prioritize
the really good thing about looking at
cloud bigtable with hbase
is you'll find most of the concepts
map very seamlessly between the two
systems
and that's obviously because of the
shared history both bigtable and hbase
have had
for a long period of time now so all the
fundamentals are going to be the same
for you
if you know how to design schemas on
hbase you're going to be pretty good at
designing them on
cloud bigtable row keys column families
column qualifiers cells they're all
going to be the same on cloud bigtable
even the cases where there are some
differences in the feature sets that are
available
such as namespaces you will find ways to
simulate them
within cloud bigtable using things like
row key prefixes
now some of the terminology you're used
to such as regions
are going to be slightly different we
call them tablets in cloud bigtable
very similar though the really good
thing though is all those concerns are
automated and fully managed for you
so you don't really need to worry about
them anymore similarly things like
snapshots that's now available as manage
backups
and tasks like compaction so you can't
configure that but it is automatically
managed for you
so there's no maintenance work you need
to do on the compaction garbage
collection size
all in all cloud bigtable supports hbase
client libraries
from 1.0 through 1.3 so you should find
the development environment
very familiar for you
now if you look at the architecture of
cloud bigtable you'll see a lot of
similarities here as well
for replicating data replication to
other clusters
can send different types of traffic to
different clusters so we have
a way to set up policies through a thing
called app profiles
that talk about how failover happens and
how you want to
re how you want to route your reads and
writes on the system
scaling is very simple in cloud bigtable
it's as simple as adding nodes
or even removing nodes within the ui or
command line interface
a table is automatically sharded into
blocks of rows called tablets and this
is all managed behind the scenes we use
a bunch of heuristics around
total data size and traffic to do this
for you
one of the really interesting things is
on the storage side
this is an automatically scaling storage
system as well
where they're stored encrypted at rest
on disk
and even if you're only running a single
node
of cloud bigtable rest assure that your
data is durable across
multiple machines now when you're
looking at
migrating your existing workloads into
cloud bigtable the first step is always
around preparation and planning
for the migration so typically you want
to do a deep dive
into the different use cases that you're
running on hbase
and perhaps you'll go down a different
path for different types of use cases
it's really good to build up an
understanding of cloud bigtable and
where some of the concepts
and capabilities might differ than what
the alternatives are
so you want to map concepts schema
design queries
and how you're thinking about data
consistency from hbase to cloud bigtable
now there are some slight differences in
supported functionality between
hbase and cloud bigtable we have
documentation on this so i encourage you
to read through the documentation and
have an
understanding of where those differences
may play early in the process
now depending on the use case you could
end up going down a variety of different
paths
some of them you will find incredibly
easy some of them might require some
more planning up front
so we're going to look at the four
different types of workloads and each of
the different migration strategies
and we'll walk through them all so let's
start with
batch load and fast serve in this
specific migration path
we only have a single writing component
and this simplifies things a lot
so this is a batch job that might be
refreshing data periodically such as
models that you're serving out
but then you're using hbase to have that
fast serve capacity for that data that's
been
written into the system now the obvious
first step here is to update the batch
job to write into both
hbase and bigtable at the same time once
this is done
now you can spend some time verifying
the batch job to make sure
that it's writing the same information
into both systems
after this is done we can roll out a
change to the api layer
that is reading from hbase to also
support
reading from bigtable once you're happy
with the performance of the system you
can
cut over to reading purely from big
table and then update your batch jobs to
stop riding into big table
at that point in time once you're happy
with the performance you can start
decommissioning
your old system
now when downtime is acceptable this
really simplifies thing and this is by
far the most common migration path we
see
it works for all types of hbase
workloads as long as you can accept a
short down time and the downtime will
depend upon the size of the data that
you have in the system
so obviously at this point you stop
writing into hbase during the migration
window
a slight difference depending on your
type of workload you could leave the
system in a read-only state or perhaps
you bring down the entire system for
maintenance
you'll then batch copy the data from
hbase into bigtable
and we have things like dataflow jobs
that can read sequence files
and do fast loading into bigtable for
you
then you want to switch over your
serving path
from hbase to bigtable and perhaps do
some calls
to check between the two systems to make
sure they're in a consistent state
at that time you can exit your
maintenance window
and resume writing but now into the big
table system
a more complex migration is where you're
migrating with the system
online but your data has a time to live
and so this is a
common workload pattern where you're
using bigtable for something like
more persistent caching or perhaps you
have data set
that has a natural cycle perhaps it's
updated every day and recalculated
so what this allows you to do is to have
the code that writes
updated to write into both hbase and
bigtable with the same time to live
information
you then simply wait until the time to
live all previous data in the system has
expired
at this point hbase and cloud bigtable
should be in sync
you can run verification to make sure
everything's performing as expected on
the right path
once you're happy with that you can
update the read side to start reading
from cloud bigtable
wait for the information to finish
expiring from hbase once you start
writing into it and then you should be
safe
to decommission your existing system and
you've migrated without downtime
onto bigtable the last one and this one
is more complicated
this is where you're migrating a
workload that has persistent data
without downtime
so once again the first step here is
updating
the right layer of the system but you're
also going to want to look at the read
layer of the system
once you've got the updates writing
to both hbase and bigtable
you want to run a verification that
that's happening correctly
and start batch copying all the existing
information that's in bigtable
once you've migrated all the information
your two systems should be in sync
you can then migrate the read workload
verify performance of the system and
start decommissioning the old system at
that point in time
now this one can take a little bit
longer because you have to have
both the dual riding up front and then
the backfill operation so it's sort of a
combination of some of these previous
approaches
now perhaps hbase isn't the only type of
workload you've got
so if you've got cassandra as well which
is also very similar to cloud bigtable
i highly encourage you to tune into our
session on migrating cassandra workloads
into cloud bigtable
and if you've got dynamodb we have
another session that talks about
migrating that
into bigtable and cloud spam you can
also watch cloud bigtable
in action through our showcase demo done
in partnership with spotify
we really encourage you to look at that
demo and if you want to get hands-on and
try it yourself
we have the quick labs for bigtable that
you can go through
get some hands-on experience and there
is also the hbase to bigtable migration
guide which walks you through some of
the technical steps here
commands to run and tooling that's
available so i want to thank you for
tuning into this session on modernizing
hbase
workloads i hope you got something out
of it and i'm looking forward to seeing
you move
to a more managed future